Bali island of gods a green paradise or
a paradise lost'
Bali island of garbage in Bali we
generate 680 cubic meters of plastic
garbage a day that's about a 14 story
building and when it comes to plastic
bags less than 5% gets recycled we know
that changes the image you may have of
our island it changed ours too when we
learned about it when we learned that
almost all plastic bags in Bali ends up
in our drains and then in our rivers and
then in our ocean and those that don't
even make it to the ocean they're either
burned or littered so we decided to do
something about it and we have been
working for almost three years now to
try to say no to plastic bags on our
home island and we have had some
significant successes we are sisters and
we go to the best school on earth Green
School Bali Green School is not only
different in the way that it is built
out of bamboo but also in the way that
it teaches we are taught to become
leaders of today something a normal
textbook cannot match one day we had a
lesson in class where we learnt about
significant people like Nelson Mandela
Lady Diana M hawa Gandhi walking home
that day we agreed that we also wanted
to be significant why should we wait
until we were grown up to be significant
we wanted to do something now sitting on
the sofa that night we brainstormed and
thought of all the issues facing Bali
and one thing that stood out to us the
most was the plastic garbage but that is
a huge problem
so we looked into it was a realistic
target for us kids plastic bags and the
idea was born we started researching and
let's just say the more we learnt there
was nothing good about plastic bags and
you know what we don't even need them we
were really inspired by the efforts to
say no to plastic bags in many other
places from Hawaii to Rwanda and to
several cities like Oakland and Dublin
and so the idea turn into the launch of
bye-bye plastic bags in the years that
we have been campaigning we have learned
a lot lesson number one you cannot do it
all by yourself
you need a big team of like-minded kids
and so we formed the bye-bye plastic
bags crew the volunteer team includes
children from all over the island from
both international and local schools and
together with them we started a
multi-layered approach based on an on
and offline signature petition
educational and inspirational
presentations at schools we raise
general awareness at markets festivals
beach cleanups and last but not least we
distribute alternative bags bags like
net bags recycled newspaper bags or 100%
organic material bags all made by local
initiatives on the island we run a pilot
village home of 800 families the village
mayor was her first friend and he loved
our t-shirts so that helped we focused
on making the customers the wear because
that's where the change needs to happen
the village is already 2/3 along the way
of becoming plastic bag free our first
attempts to get the government of Bali
on board failed so we thought hmmm a
petition with 1 million signatures they
can't ignore us right right but who
would have guessed 1 million signatures
is like a thousand times a thousand
we got stuck till we learnt lesson
number two think outside the box someone
mentioned that the Bali Airport handles
16 million arrivals and departures a
year but how do we get into the airport
and here comes lesson number three
persistence off we headed to the airport
we got past the janitor and then it was
his boss's boss and then the assistant
office manager and then the office
manager and then we got shuffled down to
levels and thought well here comes the
janitor again and after several days
knocking on doors and just being kids on
a mission we finally got to the
commercial manager of Bali airports and
we gave him the bio plastic bag speech
and being a very nice man he said I
cannot believe what I'm about to say but
I'm going to give you authorization to
collect signatures behind customs and
immigrations in our first hour and a
half ere we got almost a thousand
signatures how cool is that lesson
number four you need champions at all
levels of society from students to
commercial managers to famous people and
thanks to the attraction of green school
we had access to a steady stream of
celebrities Thank You moon taught us
that Secretary General's of the United
Nations don't sign petitions even if
kids us nicely but he promised to spread
the word and now we work closely with
the United Nations Jane Goodall taught
us the power of a peoples network she
started with just one Roots & Shoots
group and now she has 4,000 groups
around the world we are one of them
she's a real inspiration if you're a
fellow Rotarian nice to meet you we're
interactors the youngest Department of
Rotary International but we have also
learned much about patience how to deal
with frustrations leadership
work friendship we learn more about the
Balinese and their culture and we
learned about the importance of
commitment it's not always easy
sometimes it does get a little bit hard
to walk your talk but last year we did
exactly that we went to India to give a
talk and our parents took us to visit
the former private house of Mahatma
Gandhi we learned about the power of
hunger strikes he did to reach his goals
yes by the end of the tour when we met
her parents again we both made a
decision and said we're going on a
hunger strike and you can probably
imagine their faces it took a lot of
convincing and not only to her parents
but to her friends and to her teachers
as well saba and i were serious about
doing this so we met with a nutritionist
and we came up with a compromise of not
eating from sunrise to sunset every day
until the governor of bali would agree
to meet with us to talk about how to
stop plastic bags on bali our mullah
makan as it is called in bahasa
indonesia started we used social media
to support a goal and already on day two
police started to come at our home in
school what were these two girls doing
we knew we weren't making the governor
look his best by doing this food strike
we could have gone to jail but hey it
worked 24 hours later we were picked up
from school and escorted to the office
of the governor and there he was waiting
for us to meet and speak being all
supportive and thankful for a
willingness to care for the beauty and
the environment of Bali
he signed a promise to help the people
of Bali say no to plastic bags and we
are now friends and on a regular basis
we remind him and his team of the
promises he has made and indeed recently
he stated and committed that Bali will
be plastic bag free by 2018
also at the International Airport of
Bali one of our supporters are planning
to start a plastic bag free policy by
stop handing out free plastic bags and
bring in your own reusable bag is our
next message to change that mindset of
the public our short-term campaign one
island one voice is all about this we
checked in recognized the shops and
restaurants that have declared
themselves a plastic bag free zone and
we put this sticker at their entrance
and published their names on social
media and some important magazines on
Bali and conversely that highlights
those who do not have the sticker so why
are we actually telling you all of this
well partly it is because we are proud
of the results that together with our
team we have been able to reach but also
because along the way we have learned
that kids can do things we can make
things happen assemble and I were only
10 and 12 years old when we started this
we never had a business plan nor a fixed
strategy nor any hidden agendas just the
idea in front of us and a group of
friends working with us all we wanted to
do was stop those plastic bags from
wrapping and suffocating our beautiful
home kids have a boundless energy and a
motivation to be the change the world
needs so to all the kids of this
beautiful but challenging world go for
it
make that difference we're not telling
you it's going to be easy we're telling
you it's going to be worth it us kids
may only be 25% of the world's
population but we are 100% of the future
we still have a lot of work to do
but know that we will not stop until the
first question asked when arriving at
the Bali airports will be welcome to
Bali do you have any plastic bags to
declare
Oh